all right yo bootleg
podcast man we're in new york city in a
hotel room
setting up shop man chris brickley is
here and thanks for having me i've
watched so many
interviews over the years so this is
kind of cool to be here hey it's cool to
talk to you
it's crazy because i was already kind of
hip to who you were like i would see you
on like
because i follow a lot of just these
hoop pages you know
but what really kind of had me like dive
into your [ __ ] was a
gary vee interview it was like two years
ago right two three years ago was a
while ago
yeah and um and your come up man was so
like inspirational
um for people because you were you was
it you were homeless for a second
um or was it like because i think i
remember like i mean it's been
since then since it came out that i
remember watching but i remember like
just hearing about like how you got
like you were going to college right yep
give give us
give kind of a refresh on your come up
man
yeah so you know i grew up in new
hampshire small new hampshire you ever
been to new hampshire
i might have no no i haven't yeah
yeah so but grew up in new hampshire uh
you know played basketball is really
good top 100 in the country
and then ended up going to louisville as
a walk-on so i played a little bit but
i knew i wasn't going to the nba um
coach pitino was the coach i was gonna
ask is that patina
yeah okay so he has a huge coaching
treat so i'm like i'm gonna get in the
coaching so you know i was the
youngest division one assistant coach in
the country um
you know i did the coaching thing uh
was with the knicks player development
youngest nba player development coach
um no so once i left louisville i was at
ga ole miss that was my first stop
okay then i was the youngest division 1
assistant coach in the country of philly
dickinson new jersey
and then uh i landed the next job i was
the youngest player development
director but like all these jobs like in
coaching you don't make money like that
you know even when i was with the knicks
you make like 60 000 you live in
new york you cut that in half that's
yeah so you know i did that for like
four years
built a bunch of relationships and then
i uh
i was like you know what i'm just gonna
start my own business but i didn't
really know
exactly like how i was gonna do it and
then that summer was i think this summer
you're talking about
i you know i went through a little
period where i didn't i didn't have a
place to stay
right um so i was just like maxed out
all my credit cards it was bad i was
like damn i shouldn't have left it next
cause i
had two more years left in the contract
believed in myself though
and uh it's worked out yeah a lot of
people wouldn't have uh
voluntarily left the job with the knicks
not for sure my family wasn't happy
yeah so talk about that summer and you
you leave
what was like the you know because
anytime i feel like anyone ever takes a
chance on themselves
there's a breaking point where you're
like damn did i make a mistake
or you know before things start going
the right way what was that low point
for you during that period
yeah so you know so i left because me
and camilo anthony were super close so
i'm like all right so the last four
summers i'd
meet lebron i met katie i met james i
met russ so i kind of knew him i didn't
have relationships with him but i know
him
so my god if i leave the knicks i think
i could like start a training business
uh you know so i left the job as health
insurance you know it's it's a whole
you're leaving a job a good job so i
left
and then i'm thinking like right off the
bat i'm going to be able to
lebron's going to come to my gym and
katie and didn't work like that right
off the bat you know it took a minute
it took a little bit and uh so you know
i think like a few months in
middle of the summer i'm like damn i
don't know if i made the right decision
like i really don't know if i
wasn't making any money uh it was it was
it was a struggle
and then that was when i came up with
black ops and i started doing these five
on five games and that kind of like
changed my life like you know put
together these pickup games that
arguably you know some of the greatest
pickup games ever yeah get
kind of let me know what like with the
black ops thing with the 505 pickup game
it's kind of great so
black ops is like my business it's i
work up elite nba guys
and i do these five of five runs in the
summer so lebron comes through katie
you know i've had like 25 all-stars i've
had uh
the last seven mvps like everyone comes
through
and um it's exclusive it's dope media
the media loves it
and uh yeah so yeah so i guess that's
kind of uh
for people who don't know you're the
you're like the
it trainer in basketball you know what
i'm saying
yeah i mean i get i guess it's you know
as you know when you're in it you don't
think that
but for sure yeah i think um
what some people don't understand is
like
if you're lebron if you're mellow
because i always remember seeing mello
was in with you
heavy when he wasn't like back in the
league yeah you know
um and you have you know especially if
you're on an nba roster right
like there's coaches on those rosters
you were one of them right
um why go to you yeah
i mean that's that's a good question um
you know i study the game i just
i know the game and i know how to
understand people i
i know what motivates james and i know
what motivates mello
and you know you need to figure that out
otherwise they're not going to talk to
you you could you could try to coach
them it's going to go in one ear out the
other
so you need to build a relationship with
them you need to study the game
and uh you know at this point now i have
like such a big name
within basketball uh i can almost like
work with who i want which is like a
super blessing
um i try and like super thankful because
just three years ago
i was hoping i could get just three guys
a day type stuff so
life's really changed it's uh and then
you know i
was the first train ever to be in nba 2k
so i'm my own character yep yep first
trainer
sneaker deal just doing things that
trainers have never done just trying to
like inspire kids that
if you don't make the nba you could be
like me yeah cause you know
i think like uh people don't understand
like the full
grind of getting to the nba like just
because you didn't make it to the league
and you know we think about this with
coaches too right like a lot of coaches
like
may not have even been great in the nba
you know what i mean for sure but um
that doesn't mean that you don't know
the game that doesn't mean that you
don't know like the technique you know
what i'm saying
like for the disconnect for people who
are watching this they're like yo why
why the [ __ ] would lebron james go train
with this white boy like
you know what i mean like what talk
about the skill set that you bring to
the table like what are you helping
these guys work on
yeah so i guess one of my specialties is
so you know mellow has
great footwork right so when i was with
the knicks i started learning this
footwork
and then guys would come to me being
like i want some of mello's footwork so
got kawhi leonard um got kd i got you
know
so i i specialize like in that mid post
area this was like footwork
moves um and then you know working with
james i kind of
learned a whole nother uh so when you
work with like these super superstars
i'm learning from them and they're
learning from me it's like a two-way
street so then when i work with like the
regular mba guy
i have so much knowledge that i can it
really helps but with the superstars
that
we're both learning from each other with
james harden like
he's somebody who i've been following
since college
when he was at asu and uh i love
watching james harden play now there's
some people who hate watching james hard
i would say that he's probably one of
the more polarizing guys in the league
for sure it's like him and westbrook for
sure
like when you watch the sports tv shows
yeah they either love him or they hate
him
axe he's changed the game like just the
way he plays it off the bounce
you know so so what the haters say oh
you know he dribbles too much
he uh travels he you know but really
he's he's been extremely creative and
uh he's kind of revolutionizing the game
as far as how to play off the bounce no
one can stop him well yeah that
that that step back is something that
everyone mimics now
exactly yeah was that something that
like you would notice when you were like
training with him or you'd be like like
did you like help him fine-tune that a
bit
i'm not so so what he's big on in the
workouts is he likes to uh
he's like all right chris just throw me
like he wants me to give him like
super hard moves like like instead of
doing working on one move
it'll be like four moves at once so he
his his big thing is like
just try and challenge me as much as
possible with the ball so once the game
comes and have one man in front of me
doing one move is easy yeah so you know
uh
i think james is could be mvp in my
opinion this year yeah yeah well listen
man
oh and b got injured and i think he was
probably the favorite
uh lebron's out yeah he was probably the
second guy
yep and i think now it's either harden
or
jokage yeah yeah yogurt is nice jokic is
a beast
yeah or you know if if they'll stop
hating on my phoenix sons you know
give chris paul and devon booker a look
that's what i'm saying they're playing
good they are man they are
yeah um out of everybody you've trained
like
who would you consider to be like your
closest friend
like someone who like you know cause
some people you know you work with them
they're associates it's all love but
like when the training stops it's like
well i'll see you next time
then you have friends you know what i
mean yeah um i would have to say
it's like a mix i would say you know
melo donovan mitchell
d'angelo russell j.r smith
i would say those guys with melo
you were training with him a lot a lot
of videos were like coming up on my
timeline when he was not on a roster
when everyone was counting him out
for sure and that was obviously a huge
mistake
yeah it was um man i won the breakfast
club one time
and i said i think mellow this is when
he wasn't in the nba
i said i think that mello is better than
60 percent of the nba right now
the media like destroyed me i thought i
was gonna get cancelled
and four months later this guy's
starting in the nba
which means if you're an nba starter
you're better than somebody
so it's funny how the media works um
mellow's back year 18
he's playing great this year yeah man i
think like that just shows you like with
mello like
this guy's one of the most prolific
scorers in nba history
sure top ten yeah and it's and like he
never had any like crazy injuries or
anything i think people just like just
thought like
the league had moved past what he does
and it's like that's not he just
ended up in shitty situations with
oklahoma city and houston like
mike d'antoni did not [ __ ] with him you
know what i mean like
so i'm glad he got that second chance
yeah what do you think is the biggest
misconception about someone like
carmilla anthony um
i personally hate it when someone's like
all right because he didn't win a ring
then i'm gonna you know not give him the
credit for
you know some people are on that and i
understand to for your legacy but
at the end of the day yummy people play
in the nba i think he's ninth all-time
scorer for all time like he's done some
amazing things he hasn't won a ring
hopefully he will win a ring
but you shouldn't be judged just off a
ring yeah i think like you said
how many like when you really break down
how many people have rings compared to
the
people have played in the league it's
it's it's insane i even think during our
era like
the last 20 years it's been harder than
ever to get a ring
these but these super teams right yeah i
mean look even if you go back to like
when the celtics got ray allen and kevin
garnett that was to me the first
that was like the first super team of
this era yeah
where it was like oh and free agency
they just got they just went and got a
big three and then they won the ring
year one yeah that was the beginning of
it and then the
spurs had a dynasty mm-hmm which you
know and then of course there was
the lakers and yeah you know and then
and then the heat
yeah and and then the cavs and then the
warriors yeah
yeah it's it's pretty wild man um you
also [ __ ] with a lot of rappers so
some of these these pickup games you'll
be having are like
the who's who of hip-hop running up and
down the court for sure
now the the guy who i have always heard
now i've seen cuevo play cuevo
you know obviously he hooped for that
bleacher report [ __ ] and did his thing
but the guy who i always hear is the
best mm-hmm is cole
yeah hands down it's j so so you're
saying colt out of all the hip-hop
artists rappers it's j cole jacob's the
best and so
uh yeah so you know before kovy we we
worked for like
six seven straight months i mean j cole
just uh
working on his shot working you know he
would religiously i think he'd go to the
studio during the day and at night
we would work out like every night and
then he started playing in the black ops
nba runs so i'd be nine very good nba
players and he'd be on the court
and he was playing really good and uh
now he can really hope it's not even
close as far as like that's some good
rappers
that are good but he could like hang
with the player overseas right now he
could yeah he's
he's worked on it and he's good yeah
when someone puts that much time and
effort like you said for
like for however many months they must
be serious about trying to get better
at basketball yeah there's been rumors
that he might be trying to make a run
to get in the league is that something
that he's got that that you know that
like might be maybe on his goal list
yeah um i can't speak for him maybe i
guess we'll see
i mean the pistons man you know we'll
see thank you i think there's a few
teams that could literally use anybody
and the pistons are one of them yeah
no i wouldn't be surprised if it happens
but it hasn't happened since master p
he's better than master p he's better
i've seen the mess
i've seen master p clips has is he
better than any nba players you've
trained
you don't got to tell me who no so i
would say so
let's be honest so if he were to be a
pro he'd be a shooter right
he's a better shooter than some of the
guys for sure
for sure so he'd be a spot-up shooter
he'd be a shooter j.j reddick
yeah he'd be that type of thing except
jj reddick like was really good with
moving out the ball
i think he'd just be more of like a spot
up shooter cole would be the he would be
the uh
i'm trying to think who else he'd be
kyle korver in the corner he had he had
six seven game winners in the black ops
games and like the nba guys would be so
pissed like
every time he'd do it because they were
really trying and maybe hitting game
winners
his ice in his veins wow that's crazy
um with with with basketball right now
there's obviously kovit has been
happening
this last season and this season has the
kovic [ __ ] like affected your business
at all
like players like what kind of protocols
they got to go through to do outside
training and [ __ ] for sure for sure this
pass off season wasn't regular like i
couldn't do as many workouts as i wanted
i couldn't do the five-on-five runs
but you know thank god to just
everything that's
you know signing these deals i've been
i've been blessed to over this covet
period to
still sustain body armor and lids and
stockx and
so i've been i'm i'm thankful break down
some of these deals you're talking about
man you just ran through some big brands
yeah so i mean it's uh it's you know
shout out my manager alex
alex coblins kind of changed my life but
yeah no it's uh
it's crazy sometimes i'll be getting
these deals and uh
you know we'll be on the phone and i'll
be like oh you just got this deal over
these three nba guys and i'm like damn
i'm like getting these deals at nba guys
it's crazy to me still is
like you're getting deals that like that
they over them
so essentially instead of them getting
the deal you got the deal yeah as the
trainer
yeah yeah and uh which is which is
really cool
that was never the goal though but it
just it just happened like that um
you know i've had my own bowl of
chipotle that was cool so you could go
to chipotle
across the country and get the chris
wrigley bowl that was fire
um i had a stockx deal i have a lids
deal um when you say you have a lids do
they give your own hat or like what is
it yeah so i i designed like two hats
that come out
across the world i so i own color blind
it's like a clothing company
so you know we made some hats with them
uh i'm in nba 2k he's deciding to deal
with body armor which is cool
puma um we got stockx
uh wilson so i actually
uh have my own like training balls with
wilson which is fire
mommy got his own basketballs yeah it's
dope
that's crazy that is crazy um
with the next generation because you
know there's always
i'd be around ethica a lot in orange
county and they always have uh
at their location they'll always have
all these high school kids it looks like
a warehouse right but yeah i've seen
that
yeah yeah so there's always like all the
young high school kids always there
you know and and some guys trained there
as well you know but
but um i know that with aau and just
kind of the way
the game has been i mean it's been a
while since since the aau should have
kind of taken over like we kind of
already kind of know who's
probably gonna be like the next it dudes
in the league
you know as long as they don't [ __ ] up
um do you
work with a lot of those like like the
younger kids whether it's high school
kids or like kids in college
that's actually my number one focus like
i don't you know i don't
you wouldn't know by my social media but
like my number one thing is getting like
the
number one eighth grader in the country
ninth grader 10th grade or 11th grade
12th grader
so then i built that relationship so
then when this they become
nba players we have that relationship so
yeah i'm big on that i'm huge on that
yeah i think like uh i just saw i think
slam just had um
like three or four variant covers with
like all kids in high school
yeah and i was like oh [ __ ] some of
these kids are huge mikey williams
kelly some of these kids have like five
six million followers they're like
sophomores in high school
yep yeah i think the first guy i kind of
noticed like that was like that was
when he was in high school with zion
yeah i was like yo this [ __ ]
i was looking at his highlights in high
school jackson and the metal ball was in
that you know
they have them yeah yo it's crazy we
talk about lamella because i think uh
lamella was somebody who there were so
many doubts
and i don't know if you ever worked with
him but i'm sure as a fan you watched
probably some of his tape did you have
an
idea that he would be as fire as he is
in the light i'd be lying to you
no i didn't um i didn't because he
played overseas you know he played in a
gb
he never really played in any like giant
platform against really good players
so i didn't know and then uh the nba is
made for him
he's great in the open court he can
shoot it i think he's gonna be a
superstar he kind of already is
yeah i mean he kind of is man but they
just put out that esp and just put out
that controversial list where he was
like number three overall
and i was like bro book is number eight
i've seen that have you ever worked with
devon booker i have yeah he's came
to uh some black ops runs we've worked
on individually
he's just such a professional he just
say tell me because i'm a sons fan and i
think he don't get enough uh
love when it comes to i mean lebron just
called him the most disrespected player
in the game right now um what do you
what do you feel about
book like working with him like you've
seen him like how good do you think he
can be man
sky's the limit i mean he can score as
good as anyone you know he's so smooth
he can shoot it he can penetrate he
plays d
he's uh and he ever he does it every
season he's like yeah
his defense has gotten so much better
for sure for sure the last few years
i love his game hey what up man how to
interrupt the boule cab podcast to tell
you
about our good friends at odd socks all
right yo
shout out to them for sponsoring the
podcast but also we're being
such a fire company and they just
introduced
their draws that's right
odd socks now got your boxer briefs on
deck
some tapatio joints and then of course
they got the best socks in the game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loop socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
uh they got all the licenses breaking
bad mac dre odb
wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these draws
i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cab and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddsoxofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 to check out thank me later so
who do you think
is in the league that might not
necessarily be showing their greatest
potential because they might be in a
situation that's a bad fit for them
i mean i have a few uh and you're right
the league's all about opportunity
like there's there's guys that are and
even just being
getting to the league there's a lot of
guys that overseas that should be in the
league
there's a lot of guys that have a coach
in the nba that believe in them
and maybe if they didn't they wouldn't
even be in the league the league's crazy
um you know you know what man you real
quickly
the knicks oh yeah emanuel quickly so
he's having a really good season but you
know tibbs is like an old school coach
so he's playing him like 18 minutes a
game as a rookie
if he was playing like 30 35 minutes a
game he'd i think he would be
you know up there for rookie of the year
that's one mo
bamba the magic i feel like he doesn't
get he
i don't feel like he's ever gotten an
opportunity yeah he just hasn't really
played many minutes he's been injured
too
right i think that's one let me give you
one more
this is a good question uh i would have
to say
just in a better opera so jaylen brown
right so he's already like really good
yeah but i feel like if he wasn't in the
celtics wasn't playing with tatum i feel
like he could be like mvp type good
really yeah he he does it all that's big
man he does it all i mean they also have
like
common like like their games are very
similar you know what i mean
yeah so it's not like he's like like you
know they're they're both wings
so there's only so much like and tatum
gets more of the shine
so i think i think wow jalen brown you
think could be a mvp huh he's that good
yeah for sure he's trained with you yeah
and i'm not even saying just because
he's trained he's
he's the real deal wow that's crazy
what about someone who's retired that
you think could still just pick up the
shoes and just
just jump right into the league and just
shake [ __ ] up that's a good question
i would have to say because
retired right retired yep not playing or
even maybe even jenny's retired
i mean think jennings should be in the
nba he played eight years and
he was good with the bucks you know he
got you got the little injury but then
he came out i think he should be
obviously jerry smith's not retired you
should be in the nba
um let me give you a better one i would
have to say uh
you know what give baron davis like be
diddy two months and i feel like he
could play in that b yo it's crazy you
mentioned brandon jennings cause i feel
like he's one of those players that i
always think like what if
i think about that with him i think
about uh o.j mayo yeah oj mayo was fire
like there's like a few of those guys uh
what with ty lawson you know what i'm
saying like
guys who are in the league that like
just some [ __ ] happen
or injury or off the court [ __ ] and it's
like
they were so good like brandon jens is
doing his thing now you know he has
tough crowd
yeah i didn't have no idea what's going
on brandon's big-time clothing company
uh one of the most popular up-and-coming
clothing companies and yeah he's doing
his thing
um in your opinion because you're you're
close to the nba
obviously you watch basketball if ever
expecting let's i'm asking you this
question assuming everybody's healthy
okay so we're not factoring anyone who's
injured right now let's say
the playoffs come everyone's healthy at
100
who do you got to win the ring the nets
the nets yep
hands down hands down yeah even against
the lakers i just don't see someone
beating
kyrie irving kd james harden lake
griffin in a in a
all every game series harris state
they're just a really good team
i just think i think the only thing that
they might be that they might be lacking
is
who's gonna guard a.d yeah no for sure
and then obviously they need to get
along
that you know yeah they gotta get along
all three haven't really been healthy
for that
they all three of them haven't played
together at once like i i think maybe it
was like six games maybe
only a few games so i mean but off
talent though you you know
two guys can have a bag i just don't
know how you can outscore the nets
like they don't even i look at it like
they don't even gotta [ __ ] play
defense
like you gotta outscore them like
someone's gonna be
open i got them they always say that
kyrie's
them at least and and this has been
going around a lot lately now that
people are all
all hot on kyrie again because people
were sitting on kyrie for so long and i
i
never understood it but i've never seen
anybody
with a better handle than kyrie and
lately the narrative
of him being the most skilled player of
all time
has been getting thrown around is
have you worked with kyrie i haven't but
like you watch him
is that something that like because he
but he i think
i like watching his highlights in slow
motion yeah because you could really
appreciate what kyrie irving does the
way he reacts
it's art his handle yeah no arguably
you you could say like pound for pound
you know he's the most skilled player of
all time what can he do
he can shoot it he can dribble he has
good footwork he finishes
the other day he dunked on someone i
mean i don't know what he can't do
yeah it's crazy right nice uh who do you
think is the
most slept on player that you work with
because i've seen you work with you were
working with cj mccollum right
yeah i would say cj mccollum i think
year in and year out he averages like 25
a game
never been all-star had a crazy year
before he got injured yeah i think he
would have been all-star this year if he
and he always kills in the playoffs you
know i think if he wasn't with dame and
he was on another team
all right he'd be all-star maybe i could
have answered that it could have been cj
yeah that's some real [ __ ] yeah he's
nice yeah no i think his his uh the way
he
started this season was like i was like
oh my god the blazers are going to be
crazy
yeah like if they're getting that out of
him like yeah yeah
you worked with him this past offseason
yeah i've worked with him for like
seven so i worked with him you know
after his rookie year after like right
around then
so i saw him sign his first 100 million
dollar deal
next summer worked just as hard then i
just seen him sign his second hundred
million dollar deal
so i've like seen i've seen it the whole
come up and
that guy works hard man we would go
double sessions
two two workouts for like four straight
months wow yeah
have you ever had a player who you
trained up and then they got that big
deal and they kind of threw you a little
bonus
like hey yo i appreciate you bro hit
this this for you yeah a few guys
for sure but i never asked either though
but yeah a few guys like can you tell us
who
have looked out nah i wouldn't want to
do that but i
you know i've gotten uh s550 someone's
bought me that player wait someone
bought you a benz
yeah i got um you know i have a
rolex uh a bunch of jewelry that's like
their favorite thing they want to buy
um yeah you know it's about your [ __ ]
car
yeah jesus
but that was like years and years of
grinding and they got you know they got
a life-changing type contract
and then they were like yo thank you
thanks for for whatever you contributed
for sure that's crazy man
is that like do you have to pay the
taxes on the car you know that's so
funny you said dex at the time
i wasn't really i'd really just started
making money money like the last two
three years so when this happened i
wasn't
i was like damn the insurance the
repairs
all of that yeah so you know i was uh
that kind of like messed me up a little
bit but
you know i did yeah i had to pay the
insurance and you know pay the the
regular site be paid the car off
completely so that's cool wow
hey man that's that's crazy um
talk about because i'm a big proponent
on betting on yourself
um and you know i always tell people who
are extremely talented
like yo you know a lot of times we look
at at um
entities and companies that are in our
field and we look at them as like
our barometer of what success is
same way like you but anybody who would
have gotten to
the knicks would have just been happy to
be there and would have been like
i gotta grind this out as long as
possible and you left voluntarily
better on yourself um just talk about
how important that is that mentality
because i feel like
it is imperative for people who are
talented and hungry to realize that
success
is not you know it's not what it's not
always what
what you think it is like you know what
i mean facts man
i think it's huge i think that's just so
many things that come with betting on
yourself like i feel like people that
you know also there's a lot of people
that say they've been on themselves but
you can tell by their actions that they
really don't
i think when you are really believing
yourself
you have like a confidence about you and
what you do and like that you
you know you know that like i know when
i
i don't care who you put on the court
with me i know then i'm going to get him
better
i know i'm going to study his game and
figure it out so it kind of gives you
like this confidence and i feel like in
life
when you when you don't have confidence
in what you do people can see that
and it's just not going to work out so
just believing in yourself is everything
and you only need one person to believe
in you too like that's another thing
you know as you're coming up you can be
believing in yourself and
30 people might say like not you're not
it you're not it but you know you get
that one gm
from the knicks that want to give me
that job and then you make the best of
it you know um
so i think we live in a society where
people especially like instagram and all
that
you we're trying to win over everybody
it's impossible
that's you know um i think it's just
just focusing on just being the best
you and someone along the way is gonna
see that and give you an opportunity
when you get the opportunity you need to
be ready
you talked about studying people's games
right and helping them like i'm
confident
i could study someone's game and um what
is something that
specifically you've done for a player
where you were like hey i've watched a
bunch of tape
i we just like we just started working
together we've been working together
i can help fix this so i guess like so
with donovan mitchell
this is like i worked with him for a
number off seasons but every off season
we have like a new goal
and so you know i'm gonna get technical
on you so he's really good at dribbling
left
and shooting yeah and when he dribbled
right and pulled up his percentage is
way lower so
we worked on him just the whole summer
just working on
picking the ball from the right and
shooting and he's like shooting
percentage went really high i think cj
mccollum
we worked really hard one summer he got
mv uh he got you know most improved
player that was cool
there's been a few times where we've
worked on specific stuff
and uh you know every off season every
player i'm not just out there like
people
think oh he's just throwing him through
drills like no we're working on stuff
specific things yeah yeah i mean i think
like the main thing that like from like
a general and
like basketball fans perspective we
always think of like guys who like have
broken shots
or can't shoot free throws and it's like
you know i think someone like donovan
mitchell is like a perfect example like
when he came in the league i feel like
no one looked at him like he was a
three-point shooter
he was very like you kind of thought of
him like d-wade mid-range game
taking it to the basket but the last two
years
he's launching them things sure you know
what i'm saying sure
and um like is is is that the hardest
thing to do is to try to
i'm not saying you did that with donovan
but i'm saying in general to try to fix
someone's shot
yes that's the hardest thing to do for
sure and because so much comes with that
like
you're fixing their shot but then like
their confidence starts to waver
because to fix your shot you're going to
become a worse shooter for a little bit
and then you become a better shooter and
guys can't handle that so what happens
is
you have your shot you try and change it
they're like man
forget this i'm going back to my old
shot because they're not patient enough
to understand that it's a process you'll
become a better shooter after
so that yeah that's definitely uh who's
someone who you helped
fix their form fix their shot is there
anybody that you could talk about
make like tweaks um i mean
a bunch of guys we've made tweaks just
like little tweaks
but you know j cole yeah if we're
talking
that was like the biggest project i've
ever had to do in my life those like
three months
used to shoot up here we completely
changed the shot and
uh that's like the best thing for a
coach to do change someone's shot but uh
and then it works yeah it works a good
shooter andre drummond needs to hire you
man that's my guy too we need to work we
got to work on the free throws man
actually because i i'm afraid that he's
not going to see a lot of playing time
in the fourth quarter if the lakers make
you know
go on a run liability yeah facts man
um what's next for you because obviously
you know
you could pretty much do whatever you
want at this point but like what is like
on your like goal list like how do you
want to build out the company what what
are the
other things that you want to try to do
in the future man yeah so i mean just
keep building up this black ops thing
you know
i've done i look at every summer like an
album so i've been i left the next four
years ago
and take cover out i've had like four
like amazing albums that no one's ever
done as far as like
the pickup games so like one off season
is an album the guys i've worked out the
guys have gotten better so
i want to have 15 more of those albums
you know i'm just getting started with
that
and then you know outside of basketball
i'm doing uh
i have an album coming out i'm like
producers speaking of albums you got an
album coming up for sure
i'm super excited about that call
welcome to the grind remember jock jams
back yeah
so it's going to be like the hip-hop
jock jams it's going to be
you know music that you can work out to
um i wanted to be like the theme music
for all hoopers
i got you know a little baby on a dirk
uh
meek fab travis
uh you got travis scott on the album
yeah trey songz
jesus christ you know that's a did you
have to pay
boogie did you have to pay any of these
people uh yeah so i'm in like the
process of that but i'm doing it
independently
um the artist is going to be able to
keep ownership of this i was going to
ask you like
with those like do they do it and then
you gotta like they do it on the stream
the honest truth is actually been the
biggest stress of my life in the last
few months so
i'm so cool with all these artists that
you know will go to the studio to make
the song
right here and then then you got to deal
with the rest
the label the business the management
the label get it clear
i got all the songs it's just the labels
these labels they don't respect me i'm
basketball i'm a basketball trainer
so you know just waiting on these these
people at the labels to
sign off on it to give the clearances to
you know
it's just a headache man but it's going
to be fire the album is going to be fun
that's a hell of a that's a dj khaled
that's what i'm trying to do i'm gonna
do it that's crazy he said travis scott
ain't nobody getting no travis scott
features out here [ __ ]
that's why what about cole so you know
it's funny that's the
one guy that uh i reached out to about
it and he's uh he's an album mode
right so he's like you know he wants the
next music that he drops he wants it to
be
his [ __ ] yeah so i understood that i
understood that is he still
actively training with you uh yeah yes
we're still
training i go to north carolina um like
a week so
not as much obviously as like a regular
offseason but
he's still training and he's you know
getting his album done
do you think he do you think he like he
has a serious chance to make an nba
roster
i don't know if he keeps improving
there's a chance for sure
at least maybe a summer league roster
yeah for sure summer league for sure
for sure it's crazy like the whole
summer league thing is like
it became its own thing and that was one
of the things i really like uh
missed this past year yeah no summer
league summer league was the [ __ ] man
facts that was that's like a fun that's
fun for fans it's good to be back this
summer
yeah definitely um well [ __ ]
you got so much [ __ ] going on albums
coming out hopefully soon
yeah i know how hard that is though yeah
june i want to come on you said a lot of
big names so you got to talk to a lot of
all the red tape with some of the like
in just in general like you said it's so
easy to get the record out the studio
and get it on your phone and in your
email
but to actually drop it for sure there's
a lot more that comes with that
can you see yourself ever going back to
coaches coaching in the nba or on
on a college level sure um i think i
would want to be like a gm actually kind
of run a team just with the
relationships i have understand the game
that'd be cool
i'd be an nba assistant coach maybe but
right now
i'm making so much that they couldn't
pay me enough i'm making more money than
they're making for sure so it would have
to be something where you were like all
right
like this is something i want to do yeah
exactly but i would love to be like a
head coach one day
a gm would be crazy i always cause you
know we all play 2k and we always make
trades and you know that'd be dope
i think gm would be insane that's uh i
would like that hey in your opinion
let's say you're a gm right
pick a team what's a trade that you
think should have happened in the off
season that didn't happen
i think i mean the one i think of was
like yo how did kyle lowry and i could
[ __ ] trade it he was walking back to
the locker room crying like he was like
it was his
last raptor you're saying in this this
like prior yeah this year we just had
the trade deadline pass what was the
trade you think needed to happen man
man that's a good question
uh i don't know i can't even answer that
i want the knicks to get someone else
then next time they can you know i'm a
big [ __ ] that's your team
yeah so they're like in the playoff run
julius randle's all-star i want them to
get like another all-star caliber player
i was thinking they might [ __ ] around
and try to get russell westbrook to be
honest they were trying to get cj
mccollum too they were trying to you
know there were devin booker rumors
because leon rose is i know i know i
know about it leon i'm aware
but uh with the two seed bro yeah
he cannot have book that's sons he's
finally winning yeah
let me let me get your opinion on the
sons what's your opinion on what the
sons have done this year
playing great i think cp and book are
like a
tough combination i think uh i like
d'andrea too
what do you think is missing with ayton
because i think i watch ayden and
sometimes i get frustrated because i
feel like he's not as aggressive and not
as like
skill set i think like around the rim
you know
i think the other night like shaq was
talking about it he you know
he should have just done a little lefty
hook and instead he shot
and got blocked just like little just
like have skills no
have a lefty hook have a righty hook
have an up and under stuff like that
i'll pay five percent of his training
costs if we can get deandre in this off
season to come training with you in fact
that's my guy too
man i need that seems like the sweetest
dude yeah he is
yeah seems like a real nice dude man i
just like sometimes i'm like dude
you have to you know impose your will
yeah i want him to dunk on people and
scream at them have like that dog in
them yeah
yeah sure yeah man well look um go
follow him on instagram
um you got a real dope story and
congratulations on all the success man
cause i think that
anybody can look at what you've done are
you ever planning on writing a book or
anything
yeah yeah that's in the works for sure i
think anybody can look at your come up
and apply it to their own lives in any
field or any you know whatever they're
doing i appreciate that so you know
hey it was nice to link with you it
means a lot and hopefully we'll see you
you know on an nba bench one day or not
honestly [ __ ] that you don't need that
straight up like we're talking like you
don't need that [ __ ] you'll do that if
you want to yeah
boom exactly perfect thanks appreciate
you